one of your pet peeves is people
sticking their fingers down your throat
I like being a huntress I'm not a fan of
the finger in the mouth when I'm yawning
you know I know okay with it but not me
what up peeps it's 9:00 in the morning
Veronica's here 9:00 in the morning
she's coming over early I got like four
and a half hours of sleep but I'm ready
to rock this what got two hours of sleep
oh damn dude so that's what's happening
that's how much we care to watch the
trailer for interstellar that is right
yeah she doesn't know what that is right
you're the first one to come up with
that one it's sarcasm I'm sorry can we
ski sure I left a little bit no why
should i after you okay fine yeah yeah
hey yeah okay so this is Christopher
Nolan's new film do you know that is um
you have to ask me all these questions
around the camera he did the Dark Knight
trilogy he did inception a couple of
other huge movies I honestly was a
little okay hears it sucks I did a
trailer reaction for the first trailer
and I was a little disappointed and then
I saw the trailer again and I was like
this is a really cool trailer good
everyone thinks I hated the first
trailer so yeah let's watch this trailer
yeah asses off nice assume your
trademark I go into Superman then put
your glasses on oh you're a cute little
nerd you look really good in glasses
it's pretty sexy actually good job good
work you worked hard at that it stars
Matthew McConaughey oh now she's doing
the whole yawn and she's gonna put the
arm over me he's more like a Yaqui kind
of you know you sound like Johnny Depp
sometimes boom dramatic scissors out of
work Suzie Yong
not Indian surveillance true silver
salesmen Doomer she didn't do nothing
Murphy's all y'all while it's a kid or
next murkly a trained pilot and an
engineer the world doesn't need any more
engineers it's not I didn't run out of
planes and television set ran out of
food
oh it takes place in the future
yeah why did you need me after something
that's bad oh we didn't hurt he's a lot
Murphy's Law to me there's something bad
why it means that whatever can happen
[Applause]
we must confront the reality that
nothing in our service system
Canales I complain isn't my own Johannes
to the world
[Music]
and they're not meant to save the world
we're meant to leave it injures this is
the mission Boober train we've got kids
professor get out there and save them
you're coming back
oh that [ __ ] makes you cry every time
[Music]
we must
[Applause]
the sick
listen to pitcher soon
wow what an interesting cause or die's
Wow the way
[Music]
to be beautiful but IMAX
Wow
[Music]
take me with you IMAX oh I'm taking you
I will take you then when you're crying
I'm gonna hold you and then you're gonna
get all emotional I'm gonna be like it's
a cave Veronica and that's when a lion
snakes a little kiss and like kissing on
the forehead and I go with a cheek and
then she turns around and we're just
really slow like he's not exactly
insulting me ya know that movie does
look really good
I love a good futuristic movie that's
not likes flying cars and lasers and
like just craziness it's it's realistic
yeah it's realistic it's such an
interesting story I love the whole
concept of it Matthew McConaughey I
forgot how attractive he was
yeah you too I just hadn't thought of
his penis or some reason good the
opposite of really skinny like he had to
grow up a lot to get that skinny oh yeah
yeah he became very bulimic for his
roles but it's all about the art I take
that back Matthew McConaughey mad
respect matters Philemon if you're
watching this watch the trailer
reactions yeah it's also my Bill Clinton
exactly what is interstellar mean it was
choses these titles where you're like
what that's it sounds like the name of
like a band or something yeah that'd be
a cool band name and they play like kind
of like Daft Punk music so it's
astronomy situated or occurring between
the stars oh it makes sense I told you
is like in our universe yeah no you you
nailed it good job good yes well guys
you Laura interstellar means tonight oh
this morning which probably might now
it's the afternoon or evening for you
unless this has been uploaded already
you might be the morning thank you for
recommending that trailer if you're new
to the channel subscribe this is good
subscribe first off Annie clarify
something there's a guy named rocks is
the best who keeps getting on my ass for
calling him a girl I thought it was a
girl
sorry for insulting you I just see a lot
of you guys's comments like I said
before and a lot of them are Corrections
yes my name is it pronounced this way
mmm
and you can you fix that Ricky Mendoza
I'm not gonna lie I am not entirely sure
where I left off on this but I'm pretty
sure I left off on Ricky Mendoza but if
you already got a shout-out then don't
listen anything all about to say yeah
yeah I mean you get a second shadow good
for you Ricky Ricky what's going on
Ricky Ricky's a good name no you don't
know that you're making that [ __ ] up
that's your theme song my friend super
Whovians SID he said he will give me the
mystique video of mystique in a porno I
said is there a porno out there about
mystique and he's he's offering to give
me that video yes I don't know I just
know I want a [ __ ] Steve are you
listening Jennifer Lawrence oh my god
just her name gets me excited super
Whovians said thanks for getting
Veronica turned on TK for movies this
guy actually did an Avengers video like
he took his favorite clips and turned
into like a music video in a way and it
was really [ __ ] cool I'd say check it
out TK for movies I will check that out
yeah man
guys a fan of cinema TK for the was TK
for Sam for the krusty krab stressor
they K yeah but there's no C it starts
with the K krusty krab starts with the
case it's crusty crab one word probably
the killer for takaku Akane
that's my made-up Japanese name Theodore
Knight tits kill for movies he kills
tits for movies dude you're sick kill it
how do you kill a tit do you really want
to discuss this